was die forschung da auf welchem weg
herausgefunden hat es wirklich ziemlich
krass mit ganz besonderen zahlen schafft
sie nicht nur traumhafte gebildet
sondern die finden sich dann auch
überall in der natur in der kunst musik
literatur und jetzt auch in der technik
ein mathematisches prinzip durchdringend
alles und hat sogar etwas mit
quantenphysik zu tun klicks um samsungs
blue chips dreimal pro woche spannende
wissenschafts videos abonniert den kanal
und aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen ist die ganze welt fatal
das ist eines der kapitel in meinem
neuen buch per aufzug in den weltraum
erschienen im rowohlt verlag und mit
diesem buch kann man in die zukunft
sehen ich beschreibe in dem buch
realistische szenarien wie den ersten
kontakt mit außerirdischen die krönung
der schöpfung in form der künstlichen
intelligenz oder den aufzug in den
weltraum
das alles wird so oder ähnlich früher
oder später passiert und warum das
begründe ich wissenschaftlich der link
zum buch ist hier unter me oder in der
video beschreibung aber am ende habe ich
noch dazu eine ganz besondere bitte in
diesem video geht es darum dass sich
fraktale strukturen fast überall finden
lassen und in der zukunft bahnbrechende
entwicklung möglich machen werden was
haben also kristalle die verzweigung
unseres blutkreislaufs ansammlung von
sternen oder galaxienhaufen polymer
moleküle um die zweige eines baumes
gemeinsam viel mehr als man auf anhieb
vielleicht denken mag all diese objekte
sind fraktale dies bedeutet dass das
große ganze ein abbild seiner einzelnen
bestandteile ist in solch einer struktur
finden sich also überall wiederholung
ihrer selbst und es ist wirklich kaum zu
glauben in welchen bereichen sich solche
fakten objekte wiederfinden quasi
überall und das verständnis dieses
phänomens ist wirklich entscheidend und
sicher nicht weniger spannend als das
knacken des genetischen codes oder das
aufspüren der dunkle materie und es
könnte uns hinweise auf die zukunft
geben zum beispiel ob dieses immer
wiederkehrende muster allgemeingültig
das ganze universum ist und somit auch
außerirdisches leben nach genau diesem
muster entstehen würde
aber von vorne schon im jahr 1926 hatte
der physiker louis frei richardson die
ersten gedankenblitze zum thema es ging
auf die frage ob turbulenter wind eine
geschwindigkeit hat wie man diese messen
kann und ob das ergebnis abhängig vom
messverfahren ist die suche nach der
antwort führte ihn auf die spur der
fraktalen muster denn ja die strömung
hat ein muster das sowohl zeitlich als
auch räumlich äußerst kompliziertes es
war fraktale selbst ähnlich den begriff
des fatalen gibt es seit den 70er jahren
er stammt von dem mathematiker benoit
mandelbrot der ihn von dem lateinischen
wort fractus gebrochen ableitete
mandelbrot meinte damit alle objekte die
auf verschiedenen größten skalen 6
ähnlich sind beispiele verdeutlichen
dass der ast eines baumes sieht ungefähr
so aus wie ein baum in klein die
kleineren röschen des blumenkohl sehen
im wesentlichen so aus wie der gesamte
chor genauso wie der fan ein fast
vollkommenes frack thales objekt
allesamt designt von der natur
mandelbrot gelang es also zu zeigen dass
fraktale strukturen in der natur
allgegenwärtig sind dazu hatte er sich
beispielsweise auch mit der frage
herumgeschlagen wie lang die küste von
großbritannien ist und wie beim
blumenkohl handelt es sich auch hierbei
den küstenlinien um fraktale auch wenn
die selbständigkeit hier nicht so
perfekt ist sind die küstenlinien doch
zumindest mehr oder weniger selbst
ähnlich und hier macht das fraktale
richtig probleme fest steht jedenfalls
ein fatal entzieht sich dem dimension
begriff den wir kennen ganz und gar es
ist nicht nur dimensional wie ein punkt
eine personal wie eine linie
zweidimensional wie eine fläche oder gar
dreidimensional wie ein ausgedehnter
körper gut erklären lässt sich das eben
an der frage nach der länge der
britischen küstenlinie wenn man sich auf
die suche nach der antwort begibt wird
man am ende eines längeren mesz
prozesses aufkommen dass die küste wo
müll
endlich unendlich lang ist fängt man an
die küstenlinien mit einem lineal in
einem atlas auszumessen besteht das
problem darin dass viele kleine buchten
nicht eingezeichnet sind eine bessere
karte zeigt dieses detail dann und die
verschachtelte küstenlinie wird länger
noch genauer und länger wird es wohl
werden wenn man um die insel läuft und
alles mit einem zollstock alles sehr
genau per hand aus mist womöglich
zentimetergenau je genauer ich vermisse
desto größer wird der effekt ein
verrücktes phänomen die küstenlinie wird
immer länger bekannt geworden sind für
die selbst ähnlichen geometrische
strukturen die begriffe apfelmännchen
oder mandelbrot menge was im kern
dasselbe ist diese menge ergibt sich
durch eine eigentlich einfache rechen
anleitung grundlage um iks hoch zwei
gleich - 1 zu lösen wurde die menge der
komplexen zahlen eingeführt um diese
formel eben lösen zu können
denn mit normalen zahlen geht das nicht
denn minus mal minus ergibt plus und
plus x plus ergibt plus also mit der
normalen zahlenwelt wäre x2 gleich -1
nicht lösbar braucht man aber und
deswegen wurde die welt der komplexen
zahlen eingeführt erstmal braucht man
dafür eine imaginäre zahl also eine
ausgedachte für die geht zum beispiel
gleich wurzel aus - 1 und diese sixx ist
daneben die imaginäre zahl super simpel
es ist quasi eine zahl mit einer aus der
quantenphysik bekannten super position
sie ist negativ und positiv zugleich um
die rechnung für größere zahlen zu
vereinfachen hat man gesagt dass es
einfach statt zum beispiel wurzel aus -
9 immer in diesem fall
wurzel aus - 1 x 9 ist sprich jetzt gibt
es nur eine einzige imaginäre zahl und
das ist die wurzel aus - 1 aber mit
wurzel aus - 1 x einer zahl können nicht
alle zahlen dargestellt werden wenn in
der zahlen menge alle zahlungen
dargestellt werden sollen
deswegen addiert bad einfach alle
anderen zahlen dazu und mit der formel a
+ b mali hat man jetzt ganz einfach alle
zahlen und die mandelbrot menge
macht jetzt genau das was man bei
fraktalen strukturen kennt man setzt das
ergebnis der berechnung immer wieder in
die formel 1
die große frage lautet dann bleibt die
so entstandene zahlenreihe auf einen
bereich beschränkt oder entstehen immer
größer werden bezahlen das ergebnis
liefert dann auch die antwort auf die
frage ob die anfangs ausgewählte zahl
zum mandelbrot menge gehört das ist
nämlich dann der fall wenn die reihe
beschränkt bleibt zeichnet man die
erhaltenen ergebnisse in ein diagramm
entsteht eben eine solche ästhetische
abbildung hierbei werden die zahlen dann
meist auch noch in verschiedenen farben
eingefärbt die struktur in der mitte
meistens schwarz das bildet die
eigentliche mandelbrot menge
hier sind die zahlenreihen immer
beschränkt nach aussehen wird es bunter
was deutlich macht dass die zahlen
folgen an wachsen im äußeren bereich
sind sie dann völlig unbeschränkt das
heißt dass die ergebnisse immer
schneller immer größer werden und ins
unendliche anwachsen
an der grenze aber zwischen beiden
bereichen wird die trennlinie mit jeder
berechnung immer feiner wie die küste
von großbritannien immer feiner und
damit länger und länger wird und wenn
man sich dieses bild dann anschaut
bleibt mir persönlich noch eines zu
sagen wow
denn wie beeindruckend ist es denn bitte
dass durch diese einfachen
rechenschritte ein solch komplexes und
gleichzeitig ästhetisches bild entsteht
da soll noch einmal jemand behaupten
dass mathematik nicht schön ist dazu
kommt natürlich noch der fall um den es
wirklich geht würde man in die
mandelbrot menge hinein zoomen also an
die grenze würde man immer weitere
mandelbrot mengen finden also immer
weitere version des ursprünglichen
bildes die zumindest fast identisch mit
dem sind selbst ähnlich eben
zusammengefasst heißt das also das
wunderschöne und ästhetische fraktale
durch sehr einfache mathematische
formeln generiert werden können und so
inspiriert dieses wohl vom reichste
geometrischen bildern nicht nur die
mathematik und die naturwissenschaften
sondern auch die kunst die
filmproduktion und das design und auch
in der musik und in der literatur kommen
forschungsteams versteckten fakten auf
die spur 2016 haben polnische
die schaffnerin und wissenschaftler
beispielsweise 113 werke der
weltliteratur genauer analysiert dabei
ging es ihnen um die wort zahl der sätze
sie hielten ausschau nach selbst
ähnlichen längen verhältnissen das
ergebnis in allen werken der
weltliteratur egal ob bei shakespeare
oder bei thomas mann sind fatale
strukturen von sprache nachweisbar und
zwar in bezug auf die häufigkeit der
satz längen als auch in bezug auf deren
abfolge von kürzer und länger einige
werke zeigten sich bei der analyse
allerdings mathematisch komplexer als
andere darunter auch das alte testament
die struktur dieser satz lang
bezeichneten die studien autoren und
autorinnen als multi fraktale stanislaw
trotz einer der beteiligten forscher
sagt die suche nach fakten enthüllt
immer wieder die hierarchische
organisation von phänomenen und
strukturen die wir in der natur finden
es ist daher nicht verwunderlich dass
sprache die einen großen evolutionären
sprung der natürlichen welt darstellt
diese korrelation ebenfalls zeigt aber
nicht nur die literatur sondern auch die
musik enthält versteckte fatale das
konnte beispielsweise ein forschungsteam
des max planck instituts für dynamik und
selbstorganisation aus göttingen im jahr
2015 zeigen demnach sind die mini
schwankungen die selbst ein äußerst
talentierter schlagzeuger in sachen
lautstärke und rhythmus erzeugt
keineswegs zufällig denn sie bilden ein
typisches frack tages muster genau
gesagt eh ne die strukturen in längeren
zeitabschnitten denen in kürzeren
zeitintervallen und eine weitere
erkenntnis der wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler die finde ich persönlich
wirklich absolut beeindruckt demnach
machen diese fraktalen muster unsere
musik wirklich besonders sie erzeugen
also überhaupt erst die magie die wir
menschen beim hören der musik empfinden
noch offen bleibt die frage wie genau
diese fakten musste entstehen
vorstellbar ist es das gehirn strukturen
dahinter stecken die selbst auch
fraktale eigenschaften aufweisen
mandelbrot hat durch seinen fraktal
begriff innerhalb der mathematik großes
möglich gemacht und übrigens am anfang
war er sehr umstritten viele kolleginnen
und kollegen hielten
seine idee einfach für quatsch aber denn
erst durch diese theorie kann sie
vielmehr beschreiben als glatter
geometrische objekte wie dreiecke kreise
oder würfel durch den faktor begriff
wird die mathematik also zu einer art
welt beschreibung die sich mit rauen
oberflächen und sogar unterschiedlichen
graden von chaos befasst denn das steht
fest chaos und die theorie der fraktale
sind eng verknüpft vereinfacht gesagt um
die mandelbrot menge zu erhalten muss
man den gleichen schritt immer wieder
tun ausgehend von einem startwert man
nennt das iteration doch sobald die
anfangsbedingungen schwanken hier also
der startpunkt sich ändert kann sich
auch das ergebnis erheblich ändern ein
typisch chaotisches phänomen und gerade
das chaos scheint im übertragenen sinne
wichtig zu sein und das nicht nur bei
dem geäst der bäume auch im menschlichen
körper und auch in anderen organismen
finden sich wie bereits angesprochen
zahlreiche fraktale selbst ähnliche
strukturen die faltung unseres gehirns
unsere adern sind fatale und auch das
nervensystem zum beispiel unser
herzschlag volk genau wie unser atem
einem fatalen rhytmus und zwar in der
minute am tag in der woche im monat und
im jahr in allen zeitintervallen ist
unser herzschlag fraktal selbst ähnlich
ein grenzbereich zwischen chaos und
ordnung der wie erwähnt von
entscheidender bedeutung ist sowohl zu
regelmäßiger als auch zu unregelmäßiger
herzschlag kann lebensbedrohliche folgen
haben sprich die fraktale struktur ist
lebensnotwendig fatale sind also nicht
nur schön sondern eben auch ganz schön
nützlich male pro selbst warnte seine
theorie auch auf finanzmärkte an und hat
beispielsweise börsenkurse als fraktale
beschrieben damit wollte der
wissenschaftler helfen risiken besser
einzuschätzen im bereich der technik
verwenden wir solche strukturen
beispielsweise bei fatale antennen die
eben einen speziellen aufbau eine
breitbandige sende und empfangsqualität
ermöglicht anstatt viele verschiedene
antennen zu benutzen die jeweils einen
eigenen frequenzbereich abdecken
ermöglichen die fraktalen strukturen
einer 1
antenne für jede wellenlänge einen
bereich mit einem guten wirkungsgrad
auch auf dem feld der medizin kann und
das verständnis fataler muster nach
vorne bringen denn sowohl gesunde als
auch bösartige zellen wie krebs zum
beispiel lassen sich mit hilfe der
fraktalen geometrie charakterisiert
daraus ergeben sich im bereich der
klinischen diagnostik neue anwendungs
chancen
die spannende frage die über all dem
steht lautet was genau hat die fraktale
mathematik mit der nichte mathematischen
natur zu tun oder ist die natur
vielleicht gar nicht so nicht
mathematisch wie sie auf den ersten
blick scheint sicher ist jedenfalls es
ist eine sehr einfache formel die eine
unmenge an phänomen in der natur
beschreibt und es ist jedenfalls ein
geniestreich der natur mit einer so
einfachen formeln mit einem so einfachen
prinzip so komplexe strukturen entstehen
zu lassen
die betrachtung dieser fraktale hilft
uns ungemein phänomene aus der natur und
ihr wachstum besser darzustellen zu
berechnen und zu verstehen es ist eine
art schlüssel zur natur forschungsteams
weltweit sind der fakten welt auf der
spur sie haben das große ziel sie auf
basis der naturgesetze besser zu
verstehen
es scheint ein großes geheimnis hinter
diesem phänomen zu stecken und damit in
der zukunft vollkommen neue perspektiven
auch für technische entwicklungen zu
schaffen hammer
das ist übrigens eines von vielen
spannenden dem aus meinem neuen buch per
aufzug in den weltraum und jetzt könnt
ihr etwas gutes tun
ich würde mich tierisch freuen wenn es
das buch in vielen buchhandlungen gäbe
also kaufte es bitte dort und
unterstützt in diesen schweren zeiten
die buchhandlung und wenn es gar nicht
anders geht hier ist der link um es auch
online zu erwerben und hier geht es
weiter mit einem anderen video aus der
edition zukunft robert per aufzug in den
weltraum den kann man nämlich schon
heute bauen wieso weshalb warum
draufklicken und nicht dumm sterben
würde ich mal sagen bis dahin bleibt
dran